good souls
if we point them to him
he is
pray for our community
for each of us too
that's how he said love one another
go become evil
love is to be given and love is to be
shown
love is to be demonstrated
i have seen great love
in the last few days
we have had some great
people
just ordinary ones we might think
but they have done great things
in the most difficult times and
circumstances
let's see all of these people that are
sending this all over the world
my phone keeps running out of power
because of too many people telling how
much they love us
[Music]
trust in his strength
when you can't walk when you can't get
up
he'll lift you up
he will carry
i'm having just a time of silence
and you'll be done
after a few moments of silence and your
silent prayer
nathan will begin to play
there will be ministers here
maybe down in this area down here if you
need to talk to a minister
make your way down this direction
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
me
[Music]
grandmother
um
hey
from last year she wrote this
they don't have their momentum
tonight
one of